If you guys want to get your shirt, it's
available right now. All you got to do
is go to godlogicclo.com.
The link is in the description so we can
all be rocking the woods. What's what
what's the debate?
[music]
>> Uh, Rita Rita came back. How you doing,
bro?
>> How are you doing, Gabriel? Nice to see
you again.
>> Nice to see you, man. Nice to see you.
>> I hope all is well.
>> Yes, sir. Pretty good.
>> Good to hear. Good to hear you.
>> So, what what do you think of the topic,
man?
>> Yeah. So, you did tell me last time that
um like even though lives have different
topics, if we were having a topic last
stream, then we could continue this
stream.
>> Absolutely.
>> Um so, I
>> before we do that though, before we do
that, I do want to ask you a question at
least pertaining to my topic.
>> Yeah, I was I also did have a proof
ready pertaining to the topic as well,
but I did want to confirm that I could
also like respond.
>> You sure can. You sure can.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So, so what do you think? Do
you think uh you think that Muhammad's
the best example or do you think that
you may have some moral superiority to
him?
>> Um, no. Obviously, as a Muslim, I have
to say he's the best example or else I'm
pronouncing my faith basically.
>> Um, not really.
>> I mean, I have to as a Muslim claim that
I have to make is that he's infallible.
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
>> That's deep. Okay. So, you think
Muhammad is infallible? I mean you don't
think he even can commit a sin?
>> Yeah, basically
>> you know the Quran says that he sinned
in the past, right?
>> Um so the interpretation that we use for
those are a sin in perspective to the
people who like thought he harmed them.
For example, the pagans to them that
would be a sin against them. For
example, I'll just give an example. When
Moses in the Quran, when Moses killed a
man from the uh from like Pharaoh's
empire, even though we don't believe it
was a sin, it's called them because the
people of Pharaoh's empire regarded it
as a sin against them because he took a
man from their from their life even
though he was doing
>> who regarded as a sin.
>> Uh the people of Pharaoh's empire,
>> right? So this verse doesn't say
anything about the people. It says that
Allah will forgive his sins. So if
you're saying that this has to there's
sins that you can commit against people
where they forgive you or not. That's
not what the verse says. It says that
Allah may forgive you your past sins and
your future sins. It's chapter 48:2 if
you're
>> wondering.
>> Um one interpretation I have I have
heard and I'm happy for you to critique
it because it could be false. So I'd
like to hear your critique on it as
well. M
>> um one interpretation I have heard is
that there are things that are
considered like bad for prophets that
aren't considered bad for us. Like for
example, if he were to sleep through his
morning prayer, for example, for us
normally that's not bad. It's like
unintentional, whatever. But for him as
a prophet, he should be feeling guilt
for that. He should be striving to do
better. Or if Muhammad had like as
Muslims you guys are only limited to up
to four wives but and it would be bad
for you if you went over that limit but
Muhammad he can go over that limit. It's
good for him.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So so regardless there's there's
good and bad for both parties. Now,
there's levels to it, but so what is
considered bad for Muhammad would still
be like if um um I don't know, let's say
if Muhammad said that there was somebody
equal to Allah, that's that's bad for
everybody, right? Him and
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Um and it would actually be even worse
on him since he's the prophet.
>> So, it'll be held account he'll be held
more accountable for saying something
like that than some layman who says
that, right? God logic. One thing I want
to add small tiny thing. You said it
right. Muhammad has a privilege that no
other Muslim man has that he has the
right to have an unlimited number of
wives of women. But it's not only that
the it goes even much deeper than that.
Muhammad is even he has the privilege to
even lust for any married woman. So
let's say you are married in the seventh
century and Muhammad would have seen
your wife and he likes her. He can he
can force you to divorce her to take her
from you. That's one of the 16
privileges of Muhammad that no other
Muslim man has.
>> What's the like proof for that?
>> Bring the Dal, Rob. What [laughter] are
you talking? No problem.
>> Bring the Dal. Okay.
>> As he's as he's bringing that up because
he's he has everything. He's about to
bring that up. But um I wanted to make
this point that
>> Yeah. continue. Sorry. Sorry.
>> So with this
>> I already have it.
>> Okay. He already has it.
>> Yeah.
>> So the point that I'm making is that
when Muhammad when Allah says that
Muhammad sinned,
>> he sinned whether it's uh what what is a
sin for him is not necessarily a sin for
the rest of the people, but it's a sin
for him. So in Allah's eyes, so he's not
infallible. He still made mistakes. Sin.
>> Yeah. Look, here's here's the proof.
>> Oh, there you go.
Um,
>> we're going to go to Yeah. We're going
to go to
for chapter 33 ayah 50 of the Quran
Ali. Are you Shia?
>> Yeah. I am.
>> Okay. But just to give you an idea and I
I'm sure it's also in your Shia books,
but to give you an idea, right? I didn't
know that you were Shia, but it's okay.
So, this is the for
33.
This is Sunni source but this is also
I'm sure it's in your Shia sources as
well. Privilege number 10 for chapter 33
ayah 50 and the Arabic is on the screen
as well on top. If Muhammad looks at a
married Muslim woman, this is about
Muslim women. If he desires her, then
her husband is forced to divorce her and
hand her over to Muhammad so that the
prophet can have [clears throat] with
her. INB Arabi said Arabi said this is
what the servant of the two holy mosques
has also said as was clear to the
scholars from the story of Zade ib
Muhammad the adopted son of Muhammad
which also had this meaning so the
scholars in Sunni Islam they're
explaining that yes Muhammad can even
take somebody's wife it's privilege
number 10 as you see on the screen 10 go
ahead brother logic
>> those darn Sunnis always trying to mess
up the religion huh Rita Yeah.
>> And by the way, like that's a fair point
you do give up because there are a lot
and I'm sure you know there's a lot and
like Sunni hadith books of like hadiths
that clearly show um immorality with the
prophet that we use in like debates
against them as well. So I would like to
point that out as well.
>> But this is this is literally for
chapter 3350. If you if you read even if
you don't put besides it if you read
chapter 33 ay 50 it says any believing
woman so Muhammad can take any believing
woman what does it mean any believing
woman married not married right and we
know it's in the context of his adopted
son at that time his son was named his
name was Zed Ib Muhammad Zay the son of
Muhammad the moment he starts to lust
after his adopted son's wife meaning his
daughter-in-law Zint
Allah allows him to you know take
[clears throat] her god forbid but
that's his
>> um as far as this verse um at least from
I can't speak for sonis but from the
Shia point of view I have heard that
they divorced before like um even the
idea of him wanting to marry her came
into his mind
>> no it happened because of of him going
inside his house so it The story goes
like this. One day he enters the house
of his son. His son wasn't at home and
he sees his, you know, the wife of his
adopted son Zan. And he says,
"Glory to Allah who turns hearts
basically allowing his heart to pump out
of his chest because he saw her with
little clothes." And from that moment
on, you know, [clears throat] the thing
started, the story started. And that
because of that adoption gets nullified
because Muhammad lusting after his own
daughter-in-law. It's a very known
story.
>> Yeah.
>> So what I'd say to that though is in
um
in the Quran 33:37
>> it says regarding the marriage, it says
when Z completely lost interest in his
wife, then we gave her in marriage to
you. So wouldn't that mean that Zade
lost interest in her first and then
Muhammad married after? Not that he
wanted her while they were married.
>> Yeah. Have you read a tap for it? Why
why Zade lost interest before? Because
remember Muhammad enters his house, he
sees his uh daughter-in-law. He he he
likes her. He falls in love with her. So
it's it's a basically a star emotion. So
it's it's basically a story because of
that. If I show you the Sunni sources,
it's it's very bad. Even Allah, you
[clears throat] know, because of Allah
who wants to reserve
Zanab for Muhammad, he even does not
allow the private part of her original
husband, the son of Muhammad, to not
even function anymore. And I have the
sources if you want. And because of
that, he lost interest because his thing
did not work anymore.
>> All right. Well, I'd have to look into
that from Shia sources. I can't It's a
point and I have to do research and look
into it. I've only said what I've heard
so far and I can't even confirm what
I've said because I don't have the
evidences ready. So, I apologize for
that. So, I'm going to have to look into
that from the Shia sources.
>> Um,
and yeah, basically, did you want to add
anything?
>> Yeah, I just have one I I wanted to get
to my one question with you uh in
regards to what the Quran says and is
teaching this. So what is your
understanding
of um well before I ask you this?
>> Yes.
>> Do you believe that child sex relations
is morally wrong?
>> Having marrying marrying
>> if we're defining child as before
puberty then yes.
>> Okay. So and what is your understanding
of 65 verse4?
>> 654.
>> Oh boy.
>> Yeah. Pull it off right now. As a Shia,
you don't you don't hold that Muhammad
slept with Aisha at nine, do you?
>> No, we believe she was anywhere from 18
to 21.
>> That's not true.
>> Well, we could we could put that on on
hold just for a sec. We going to see
what
>> they actually believe that she was 10.
>> Oh, they believe he was 10.
>> She was 10. Yeah. So, what the Sunnis
believe she was nine, but in Shia Islam,
and I have multiple books to back it up,
like Alfi, where it says that Aisha was
10 according to the Shia sources. Mhm.
Um but then again we don't take as fully
authorative like Muslim.
No that's not true because you say that
is more authentic but than Bkari. That's
what you say.
>> Yeah because we believe Bkari is
authentic.
>> I can show what if I can prove that it's
>> That's a different story because we also
>> that's a different story. Huh?
>> That's a different story.
>> So give me the screen brother. You know
just you know for argument sake. Look
here is
source
volume 24 Shia not Sunni look page 235
on top in the left upper corner 235
volume 24 we scroll down look the
messenger of Allah entered upon Aisha
and she was 10 years old
and we go down and lo and behold, lo and
behold, grade
boom.
>> Wow. Okay. So, Sunni say she was nine.
She is say she was 10.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> And I have multiple sources to back this
up as well.
>> Send send me that on Telegram. I need
that.
>> Do you see how they have lied to us from
the Shia side as well?
>> Yeah. Yep. It's tough.
>> Um, so, so 654, how do you understand
that, Rita?
>> Yeah. Sorry, I got off. Wait. Uh, 654
you said?
>> Yeah.
>> Rob Christian, ladies and gents. Ladies
and gentlemen.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, um, I'm pretty sure this
is talking about the waiting period.
Yes. Between marriages. Yeah. So do you
see how it says that it talks about the
older women first and then it talks
about the ones who have administrated
and then it talks about the ones who are
pregnant right
>> as well they went three months.
>> So you see two these are two different
books as you see brother god logic right
so book number one this is book number
two this is al kafi who has according to
the shia is you know b basically the
most authentic book in shia Islam and on
page literally 588 same story
Yeah, you got to send me that.
>> Send me both.
>> And like I showed you the is
>> Rob if I don't see these sources within
[laughter] 10 minutes.
>> I got you, bro. I got you.
>> Yeah. So, so you see the verse uh Rita
>> uh 654. Yeah. So, should I read it or
>> Yes. Yes. Go ahead. If
>> Okay. So as for your woman past the age
of menstruation in case you do not know
their waiting period is three months and
those who have not menrated as well as
for those who are pregnant their waiting
period ends with delivery and
[clears throat]
like it continues but that's like the
important part I'm assuming
>> right. Yep. Absolutely. So the the
important part is the second category
where it talks about the ones who
haven't minrated. So those are uh the
little girls who haven't they're
prepubescent. They haven't hit.
>> Okay. Well, can people also not
ministrate due to medical reasons,
hormone imbalances, stuff like that?
>> Uh yeah, that would be a rarity that the
Quran is not talking about. I So what I
would say is is that that would include
them, but it doesn't exclude the little
girls who have administrated either. So
this would include little girls who have
administrated and it would it would it
would include uh girls who have a health
defect.
Um, could I would you mind if I went to
my depths for just
>> Absolutely, bro. Yep. Look, we we we
learning. We we research, we learning.
Go ahead, bro.
>> As we as we looking for it, let me show
you what you if you get married to a to
an infant in Shia Islam. So since it's
sh if you get married to an infant so a
a a baby girl who is in the cradle of
her you know you got married to her you
know her parents gave you away to you
watch. So this is
volume 2 page 221
look in the bottom 221 Arabic books not
websites let's read question so this is
Q&A Shia Islam this is Sharia of Shia
Islam it's not permissible to have peep
with the wife before 9 years of age but
enjoyment like or there is no problem
even with an infant who suckling What?
The word is suckling, by the way. The
same word that we read earlier with the
Sunni guy.
>> No, that just means putting milk in the
bowl.
>> Yeah, bro.
>> Is it hadith? Like, where is this from?
I just want to know where it's from.
>> Is this your
>> I just want to remind everybody this is
Muslim Lantern's fault. The reason why
we're doing this and doing topics like
this is because Muslim lantern. This is
his fault. and he isn't here to defend
and come and uh address this stuff since
he studied the Jewish prudence and knows
all this stuff. This is his fault,
ladies and gentlemen.
>> It's tough.
>> Okay. Wait. So, this isn't like a hadith
though. This is
>> this is this is this is Shia Jewish
and Sharia and Sharia source.
>> Well,
>> this is literally the Sharia book of for
Shia.
>> Well, there's multiple Sharia books for
Shia and I can show you also. So, this
is
And I can show you also I'll suggest too
if you like both agree that you can do
the thighing to an infant and you know
what thighing means. I don't I don't
need to explain it to you to the dot.
It's tough man being a Muslim.
>> This is this is just like basically
scholars saying that this is
permissible.
>> It's not like
>> these are your you know what a is right.
Yeah, I am aware of them. But not
everybody
>> to be a Shia though you don't have to
take um
>> what is your what is who what is your
which
>> I'm in debate between and sistani
>> well sistani says the same but
>> I have here
by say theani volume 3
>> that you're going to bring up uh he did
he did redact it later in the later
volume. No, he didn't. It's
>> he did in the latest volume of
that quote is not there anymore. He
redacted it.
>> No, not true. This is why now in Iraq
they even allows allow you to marry a
9-year-old because of this in Iraq and
you know that. But anyway, brother God
Logic, thank you for having me, brother.
I need to go. This was awesome. If you
needed my help, you know where to find
me, brother.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Because God bless the and stay away from
Islam, guys. Amen. Yeah, guys, make sure
you guys follow Rob Christian. That's
literally his YouTube channel. It's Rob
Christian. Go ahead and subscribe to the
brother mods. Go ahead and put his link
in the uh in the chat if you can. Let's
go ahead and support this brother. He
should actually definitely have a lot
more subscribers than he does have. Uh
so, let's go ahead and push for Rob and
support him, man. He's a good He be
teaching, man. He has those sources on
deck.
>> Okay.
>> You ready to get back?
>> Yeah. So, six. Yes.
>> Yeah.
Um, so I'm on the book right now, the
one I told you about last time. Um, if
you want, you could find it online.
Like, it's wide open if you want to pull
it up too for yourself.
>> Is it in English?
>> Uh, yeah. Yeah. So, if you literally
just I'll tell you how to spell it. And
then
>> Okay.
>> M I Z an
>> misan.
>> Yeah. And then the first thing that
comes up should be a website called
mmisan.org.org.
>> Yeah. And then there you could enter the
verse number and then it'll take you
right there.
>> Okay. What what So there's the opening
and then there's the select the verse.
So what what
>> you scroll down to the number of the So
this would be 65. You just scroll all
the way down to 65.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. So you could select the verse
straight up.
>> Cool.
Just so you could like read along with
me. And the reason why I do like this
one is because it goes into like what a
lot of like apologetics brings up and it
like debates those points as it goes
along as well which I kind of like.
>> So is this guy like a recent type of
>> Yeah. Yeah. 1900.
>> 1900.
>> Oh, okay. All right. So, do we don't
have any like anybody from earlier, you
know? Um there's which is from like uh
300 ah. Um and there's like there's a
bunch like from along that uh time, but
a lot of them focus on like like
strictly hadith. So they just show
hadiths from that time. This one I like
because it goes into like the pmics of
it and like actually talks about
>> Yeah, he's it it seems like he's like
trying to put a band-aid on the issue
here. I hope that like he's not being
I'm I'm not trying to look for somebody
making a defense for it. I'm trying to
look for what they what is the verse
what what are they saying it means. You
get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. And this was written by a guy that
studied the Quran for like over 30
years.
>> I he's
contemporary. I I would like to see what
what do the
>> the ancient scholars
>> Yeah.
>> uh say about the issue and Shia Islam.
He's he's a kid to these guys to the to
guys. I'm ask asking about
>> well I'm not sure if there's like open
this is because this is the main one
used in Shlam. So it just that one's
like wide open. I haven't found
available sources sources for the other
ones online.
>> Okay. So what uh what what part do you
want us to look at cuz he does it's 1
through 7. Let's see.
>> Yeah. So just scroll down to verse four.
>> Let's scroll down to verse four. I put
up like So this is what I'm looking at.
>> Um Oops. There we go. All right. So this
is what I'm looking at over here on the
left. to scroll down. That's verse one.
So, you just scroll down like maybe a
couple of pages to verse four.
>> How do I know that he's talking?
>> That's only about verse one. Then it
goes verse by verse. And then, yeah,
verse four is right there on the bottom.
>> On the bottom. This
>> Yeah. So,
>> all right. That's what he says. So, he
quotes the verse. Boom. Boom.
>> And then,
>> what is this? It he's breaking down an
Arabic word
>> refer to doubt over yada yada. the women
who do not expect to get a menstrual
cycle or
>> so that was for the first part that's
the first part and then the the second
part is the paragraph right after it.
Yeah.
>> And of those who have who have not had
their courses is linked to and for those
of your women who have despared
administration
>> and
>> that's the one that you said referred to
like young little girls basically.
>> Yeah. Those women who have not yet
ministrated although they are at the age
of ministration should observe an ida
for 3 months. No. So this one said so
the word is lumedna in the Arabic lumna
means they have never ministrated. It's
never been done. So when he's saying
that this is linked with the uh women
who despair of their ministration if
they haven't had their ministr these are
two different categories. It's the one
people who despair their ministration
because they're too old. And then
there's the ones who have not menrated
yet. It looks like he's trying to say
that they're part of the same category.
Am I right in understanding that?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So that's that's that's false.
These are two different categories, but
he's trying to make them one. You get
what I'm saying?
>> Um yeah, I I I understand. I got you. So
I I the part that I do agree with him on
is when it says it's and so it's it's
it's a conjunction with the next
thought. Uh but that doesn't it's not
connecting them with the same group.
They both just have the same ida. These
are two different categories of females
though. One is the older one too old to
ministrate. So they don't know if
they're going to ministrate at all. The
other ones are the ones who haven't
minrated at all. They they're too young
to have ministrated. They've never done
it. I'm your head now.
>> But okay, so just a question. How do you
know that the non-menstruation refers to
within their entire life versus
referring to the three-month period, not
menstruating within that period?
>> It says lam and and those who have no
courses, who have not had their courses.
Ln
means they've never had it before.
>> Hasn't happened in the past. It's never
happened.
>> Well, it it says they have not
ministrated, but in what in what period
they haven't menstruated? Maybe it's
talking about the period within the
three-month period they haven't
menstruated because the verse is talking
about that three-month period.
>> The word lam lenna,
it's they've never ministrated before.
It's not in a a particular period.
They've never ministrated before.
>> Well, it directly translates to they
have not menstruated.
>> Yes. In what way? That they've never
menrated before. They haven't had their
periods.
>> But it doesn't say that they've never
menstruated in their lives. It could
have meant that they've never menrated
within that three-month period because
that's what the verse was talking about.
>> If if I if my my my goddaughter I have a
goddaughter, she's just turned seven.
She hasn't had her period yet.
>> Um and I say I I can rightly say that
she has not had her courses, right? She
has not had her minces yet.
>> I can say and for those who h uh have
not had their minces,
>> those who have not had their courses
that my godaughter, she has not had her
course. She's
>> brother God logic. I came back regarding
this. Um
>> yeah,
>> you you're very correct. Um the word
that is used in the ayah in 654 says
with a meme.
>> Now if if you know God logic would have
not had an argument if len with the noon
was used. So lem means they never had
and actually you know if you go to your
hadith can you open the link that I
posted in the chat brotherlogic it's an
authentic hadith from kafi
>> that said let him read it I want him to
read it because uh you know it's it's
the it's the fact that you're trying to
defend this yet you know it's allowed to
not only marry but divorce them after
consummating the marriage with them.
Read it read the hadith. I got you.
>> Should I read it out loud? If a man is
volume five, read it.
>> If a man marries a maid uh while she is
still young, he can't have intercourse
with her until she reaches the age of
nine.
>> Thank you very much. Done.
>> So basically, you can't
>> So 9 years old you can have inlam. What
if she didn't reach the age of puberty?
What you know when you know? Well,
that's another criteria that's given
elsewhere.
>> No, you know, it says 9 years old. The
criteria is there. It's 9 years old.
>> I know that's one criteria, but there's
also
>> say, you know, she did not, you know,
she didn't reach the age of puberty at
the age of 9. It allows you to do that.
Look, it's 9 years older
>> if she's hit puberty. Yeah.
>> No, it doesn't say that. Does it say
that? God logic.
>> Uh, the only stipulation is 9 years old.
But it doesn't it doesn't include
whether she hits.
>> There's a criteria given elsewhere that
she must hit puberty. And then there's
another criteria here that's given as
nine.
>> So this hadith is life. Is this hadith
life?
>> No.
>> Thank you very much. So are you trying
to tell us then? Are you trying to tell
us then that you have you have a
contradiction within your books and and
all of them are authentic?
>> That's tough man.
>> Okay. Well, why would it be a
contradiction? Why how how could it not
have rather been that both criterias
must be met? Is it just not understand
what showed him?
>> And then there's aith that says she must
reach the age of nine. Why are you
saying that they can't go hand in hand
in both?
>> Again, if she doesn't reach the age of
puberty and she's 9 years old according
to this authentic hadith on the screen
from it says, right, you can go you can
do it with her even if she didn't reach
because the only condition is she must
be 9 years old.
>> Yeah. The only condition in this hadith
but there are other hadith that give
other conditions.
>> Uh so forget about this one. This is
authentic thorough.
>> I'm saying that
>> what are we going to do with it then?
>> I'm saying there's one criteria given
here that she must reach the age of
nine. There are other hadiths that give
other criteria such as she must reach
puberty or that she must
>> no wait let me let me ask something. So
let let's say she reached puberty at
seven then is she is it lawful to
consummate with her?
>> You have to wait till 9.
>> See that's that's where
>> criteria both criteras must be met. This
is only one criteria but both criteria
have to be met.
>> Okay.
>> So let let me ask you this. Do you
believe that this is okay?
>> Um modern day unsure but back when it
was a societal norm.
>> Yeah.
>> Well it wasn't societal norm. Um like
that's that's what I'm we're not we're
not talking societal norms. We're not
talking cultural relativis relativism.
We're talking about objectivity. is do
you do you believe that this is morally
good?
>> So I don't I don't have the hadith on me
right now
>> but I have heard before that um another
condition is that it must be society
acceptable. So if the society accepts
>> and and so those two,
>> let's go with this. If the society
accepts that, you know, sleeping with an
8-year-old who has hit puberty is good,
then that's all that's all good. It's
morally right.
>> Well, nine.
>> Okay.
>> The same. So not it wouldn't be good if
it if it was 8-year-old be nine, right?
So let's go with these three objective
criteria. The first is the age.
>> That's not objective.
Well,
>> saying when you when you say society
sees it as okay, that's literally
relativism. You get what I'm saying?
That's subjectivity because societies
defer. Societ the same society defers
two years later on an issue maybe. You
know what I'm saying? It's it's
subjective.
>> Yeah. But um the ruling is objective
that society has to accept it. It's not
saying. [clears throat]
>> So whatever society accepts that's the
good go, right? If if society accepts
that criteria the that marriage and then
the other two criteria are met then yes.
>> Okay. So you're saying if the society
accepts uh puberty and 9 years old is
okay to consummate with a girl at 9
years old who just began puberty. You
believe that that is morally good?
>> Morally acceptable.
>> Wow.
>> Wow. Would you do it?
>> No.
>> Why not? because I don't think I'd
personally be ready like with a job and
a family and stuff like that by
>> so let's let's grant that you had this
let's say you had a job of course you're
you know a little let's say you had a
job you had housing you had money you
had your finances all together and
you're ready for marriage would you take
a 9-year-old who had just hit puberty
and society thinks that that's okay
>> I personally wouldn't accord that's my
preferences though I personally wouldn't
>> why wouldn't you
>> preference Why? What? Like why wouldn't
you? What's what what's what's causing
you not to prefer that?
>> Just preference. Like literally just
preference.
>> I know. When you say literally just
preference, we have our reasons why we
prefer one thing over another.
>> So what what's your what's your
reasoning for saying that you prefer not
to have a 9-year-old who just hit
puberty?
>> Too young for me.
>> Too [clears throat] young.
>> For me? Yeah. Preference wise.
>> But it wasn't too young for Allah.
According to Shlam, she was 10.
>> And he's saying that's okay. He's
saying, you know, Muhammad can have that
preference for a 9-year-old or a
10-year-old,
>> right? And that's his preference. That's
he's perfectly fine. He's saying, me
personally, I don't I don't prefer that.
I prefer older.
>> So, which means you have better
morality. You're more you know, you you
have been raised better than the prophet
of Islam according to that logic.
>> Well,
let me say this and then I'll ask my
last question on this and then we can
move forward.
>> Okay. Wait, but didn't you say we would
also be able to go over there?
>> You're on top. Yeah, that's what I'm
saying.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Thank you. Um, so
could you objectively prove that when a
girl hits puberty, she's not ready for
marriage? Morally, objectively prove
>> a nine-year-old
>> if she's if she hit puberty.
>> Yeah. You think you think that a
9-year-old you think have
>> I'm asking if you could objectively
prove that that's
>> Let's deal with this together. Have you
just Have you ever seen a 9-year-old,
let's even say in puberty, have you ever
seen a 9-year-old who is physically
developed and ready for true sexual
intercourse and psychologically
developed for marriage and holding down
a household and tending to her husband
and having kids and being a mother
>> today's day and age? No.
>> Right. So,
>> I have seen I have seen like very young
ages. For example, my um grandma was 13
when she got married. You seen you seen
your grandma at 13? You knew her?
>> No, I'm speaking in the past. But no,
like in person, no.
>> Okay. So in our observation, you and I
can point myself here as well, nor I
have observed ever a 9-year-old who is
physically developed, psychologically
developed, and mentally developed
>> for to even handle sexual intercourse to
um handle housing and marriage and a
woman's deeds and a wife's
responsibilities and a woman's responsib
responsibilities caring for children.
She's a child herself. So, I think that
that that helps us out.
>> But if if a woman was uh able to hold
that household, able to do all those at
the age of nine would objectively be
right according to you. Objective.
>> No. No. So, a a n a 9-year-old is a
child, brother. There's no way out of
it. Whether she believes
>> we agreed with the definition at the
beginning that someone
>> I didn't I didn't you said that. He
said, "If we mean uh someone who has hit
pu or who hasn't hit puberty, if that's
what you mean by child, then I think
that that's wrong." I granted you that
for the sake of argument. I do not
understand.
>> Okay, fine. Understood. That's fair.
Gotcha.
>> So then I would ask, what's your
objective moral proof? If a woman is
able to hold down a family, if she's
able to hold down a family, she's
reached puberty, um what's the objective
moral proof that do you know do you know
that? Do you know that puberty does not
mean that a girl is grown yet. It means
that she's maturing.
>> You get what I'm saying?
>> I understand. Yeah, I understand.
>> So, just because she begins her bleeding
period
>> doesn't mean she's ready yet doesn't
mean she's grown. She's not. She's she's
maturing. She's growing. She's still a
child. Like this is why we have what is
called pedophiles today,
>> right? And they're thrown in jail. Do do
you think that these guys who are who
have affection for these kids and
younger children 11 years old, 10 years
old, 12 years old, 9 years old, 8 years
old, do you think that the system is
justified in throwing them in prison?
>> Yes.
>> Why? Some of them have hit puberty.
>> Well, wait. Can you repeat? Like you're
talking about like child predators
basically.
>> Yeah. child predators who have to
register themselves just because they
prefer,
>> you know, like you don't prefer them,
they prefer
>> girls like how Muhammad preferred them.
>> In this day and age, I don't think uh
children at like the age like people at
the age of nine are mentally mentally
mature enough to make a decision.
>> What if there was what if there was one
who thought that she was that she
thought like, "Yeah, I'm in I'm in."
>> Thinking you are isn't the same. Think
you are the same. Okay. So, I don't
think they're mental mentally mature
enough to make that decision.
>> No, no 9-year-old ever is. There's no
not a single nine-year-old on the face
of the planet that has ever been uh
ready for marriage and mature enough to
be married or even handle sexual
intercourse. She is a child. You
understand what I'm saying?
>> I got you. But my question to you would
be if she was ready to hold down the
household and she
is no if Okay. If that condition was
met,
>> she's nine, bro. She's still a kid.
>> I got you. But
>> let's say, let's say a nine-year-old's
parents died. And so, the nine-year-old
was forced to take care of her little
brothers and she, from what she
remembers, she remembers how to make
toast and eggs, and she remembers how to
walk her brother to preschool, but she's
still a kid. Even though she's helping
her brother survive and holding down the
household, she's still a child, isn't
she?
>> In today's day and age, yes.
>> Period. But I'm asking you if that
condition was met.
>> I just answered you, bro. I just
>> I know. I understand. It's an it's a
according to you, it's an impossible
condition. But if that condition was met
and she hit puberty, would you say
objectively it's allowed?
>> I don't I don't know how many times you
want me to answer this, bro. Like what
what do you understand from my answer?
Cuz I feel like I answered this
directly.
>> Your answer is that um it's impossible
for a a person at the age of nine to
reach that maturity. So therefore it's
not allowed.
>> Yes. So what that's my answer, bro.
>> If if
>> there is no if there is no 9-year-old
that is able to withstand sexual
intercourse,
handle a marriage, be ready for
marriage, be ready to be be a wife.
There's no such thing as that. That
doesn't exist. What What if there was a
pink elephant under your under your
under your bedroom, Avery? Would you
keep it as a pet? Like that's that kind
of question. It's absurd. Um, brother
got logic. Can I ask him a different
question if it's off topic?
>> Sure. Well, it has I I told him, so it
has to be it has to be on this topic. If
it's on this topic, you know.
>> Yeah. Since we're talking about the
morality of of his prophet and whatnot,
but it's okay if he has to go. That's a
>> save it save it for the next one.
>> Sure.
>> All right. Rita, what's what's your what
was uh what did you want to
>> real quick just so I could look into it
later. Can you just summarize basically
your takeaway from the discussion we
just had about the age?
>> Yeah. So 65 chapter 65:4
>> teaches the marriage and consummation uh
and divorce of children, girls who are
who are prepubescent. Chapter 65:4. How
we know that it allows for sexual
intercourse with this example that these
girls have an is that these girls have
an ida. They have a waiting period.
Okay. According to the Quran in chapter
33:49,
you do not have a waiting period if your
husband did not touch you. Okay. That's
chapter 33:49.
It says when you divorce a believing
woman and you before you've touched her,
there is no waiting period. There is no
ida for her for you to place on her. So,
let her go.
>> Also, chapter 3349, you have to combine
it with 654. If you don't no touchy, no
touchy touchy, there's, you know, no
ida, right? That's right. So, the fact
that these girls have an ida in 654
before they've ministrated, they're
being divorced, and they have an ida, it
means that their husbands slept with
them
>> before puberty.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. But
>> what you need to do is 654. You need to
combine it with 3349.
In 3349, it says if you do not touch,
you know what touch means? If you don't
touch her then she doesn't need to wait
three months. But 654 says also for the
young little prepubescent girls the
waiting period is 3 months which means
in
>> 65 where does it say that?
>> 3349
>> and what?
>> 3349.
>> Oh god. Repeat what you said. So in
chapter 33:49 it says if you did not
touch
your wife then there is no need for
waiting 3 months the waiting period no
need but in 654 it says also four which
means the is also for
the ones who did not reach the age of
puberty yet who did not menrate yet. So
if you combine both ions it's very clear
it's clear as the sun
>> is not reaching menstruation only
possible through not reaching puberty or
is it also possible in the case of
hormonal imbalances medical problems
>> that would include if we're opening that
up if we're opening that up it includes
them not excludes them
>> okay got you so now I'm going to go back
to what brother Rob said he said combine
the two verses and Avery as you agreed
you said that um when you combine the
two verses 654
even talks about um uh woman like
preubescent woman before
>> girls
>> their husband touched them
>> sexual intercourse with them because
they right when you combine the two
verses
>> y
>> so my thing would be is would you agree
in in Islam that one of the conditions
for marriage is to reach puberty
>> no
that's nowhere that's nowhere taught in
the Quran You have to go to outside
sources outside the Quran
>> because clearly according to you Muslims
then Allah is not clear enough but yet
in a different this is a detailed book
and I know brother god log you can talk
hours and hours about the topic but
supposedly the Quran is clear according
to Allah but you have to go to the here
to make it make sense but the Quran is
very clear 3349 combined with 654 it's
clear as the sun
>> so if if the condition If there was a
condition, you said there wasn't. If
there was a condition that they much
they must reach puberty, then would you
admit that 654 was not talking about
prepubescent woman because
no Arabic is very clear. The Arabic says
lem. It does use
>> len [clears throat]
that would just mean that there's a
contradiction, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, it would mean that there's a
contradiction. Okay, fine. Fair enough.
Gotcha. Valid. Okay. Uh, so I'm gonna
look into that. Thank you guys for the
points given. Definitely going to look
into it. Hopefully like next week or
something. We could talk about it if I
join again.
>> Sure.
>> Um, so
>> yeah, Monday, Wednesday, Friday, bro.
>> Gotcha. Appreciate you for having me.
And then we can go over the next point
now. The 394.
>> Oh, is that Oh, that's what you want to
talk about? Yeah, sure.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, if you want to open it up real
quick.
>> I have my son.
>> Okay. So there are three conditional
particles in the Arabic language ether,
in and okay. Um, and brother Rob is here
as a Arabic speaker to correct me if I'm
wrong. So either is used for
possibilities that are certain or likely
to happen. So like for example like when
this happens then this other consequent
will be met. um in is used for
uncertainties which are in the middle.
So like for example, if this were to
happen then this other thing would
happen. But then la which is the same
word used for the um the same
conditional particle used in 394 is only
used for when both the condition and the
consequent are impossibilities. So, and
I do have sources to back this up from
the like leading authority on the Arabic
language currently, which is the Academy
of Arabic Language of Kyra.
>> So, so break this down as simply as
possible for us.
>> Simply as possible. The conditional
particle in the verse.
>> That's not that's not breaking it down
simply like speak like no,
>> you know,
>> the word Okay, fine. Yeah, gotcha. The
word which is used in Arabic for even
for if
>> it is only used when the condition and
the consequent of the condition are
impossibilities.
But rather you said even it's if
so please don't corrupt Allah's Quran if
you don't mind you know you know
>> look if you don't if you don't believe
me search up when the conditional
particle is used in Arabic
>> it just says
>> in the in this of the ayah in the of the
ay it's literally says if Allah wanted
if
>> so so just be clear just just help me
out rer so if obviously that is
conditional it's a hypothetical
So if if what if all I had wanted
>> if this
>> Yeah. It's used as a rhetoric a
rhetorical question to make them think
and the particle sorry it's a rhetorical
statement to make the disbelievers
think.
>> He's refuting them. Right. Right. So
he's refuting that he has a son
>> by saying if he wanted to he could have
but he he's above that. That's his
that's his response. Right. Okay. So the
question is when Allah says if he wanted
to do it he could. How can someone come
and say actually no this actually is an
impossible?
>> He doesn't say if he wanted to do it he
could.
>> It says if Allah had intended to take a
son.
>> He could have.
>> No he would have. He would have picked.
>> Oh. So if he wanted to take a son he
would have picked from any of his
creation. So could he have picked from
any his creation to be a son?
>> No. Because grammatically the particle
used at the very beginning predicts that
the condition and the consequent are
completely impossible.
>> What is the condition based on?
>> Not true.
>> Yeah, it's it's very false. We're going
to we're going to break this down
logically. What is the condition based
on?
>> The if. What is the if based on
>> the like if he could have a son?
>> No.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. So, you're saying what
the consequence of the condition is
based on?
>> What is No. What is the the Let's do
this again. The if the condition the if
what is that based on?
>> I'm so I'm sorry. I'm not understanding
your question. Sorry.
>> Just go ahead and read the verse.
>> Okay. Had it been Allah's will to have
offspring, he could have chosen whatever
he willed of his creation.
>> All right. So, what is the if?
>> If he willed to have offspring.
>> And what is the consequence? What is the
result?
>> The consequence is he would have chosen
from whatever he w.
>> Okay. What is the consequence based on?
The condition the condition that um
Allah's will was to have a
>> very good condition that Allah's will is
for it was for him to have a son. If can
he will to have a son?
>> No.
>> Is that impossible?
>> It is impossible.
>> It's impossible for Allah to will to
have a son.
>> Yes.
>> Cool. I got nothing to say to that.
>> Well, would you say it's impossible for
Allah to create a separate deity? For
God to create a separate deity.
>> You have to demonstrate how that's the
same thing. How how is God creating
another deity the same as Allah willing
to have a son?
>> Because having a son creates a separate
person with divinity aside from
yourself.
>> But you said creating, you didn't say
create a separate person or a distinct
person. You said create a separate
deity. Somebody who has their own
ontology, right? Separate from you. So
that's what you're talking about. You
have to demonstrate that that's what the
case is. Well, my proof to demonstrate
that was based on the verse because the
particle used meant that whatever comes
next is impossible. So, whatever Allah
is referencing and whatever came next in
that verse, it's talking about something
a hypothetic that's impossible that
could never happen impossible.
>> That's not true.
>> It doesn't say that. Look, as an Arabic
speaker, Rob, as an Arabic speaker, Rob,
when is the conditional particle used?
When is it used?
>> Brother, let me let me explain it to
you. If you go to chapter 112 ayah 3
remind me brother god logic what's the
word the meaning of the word again
>> never
>> never so this means Allah in the future
he can have a child so refutes you
actually so Allah can have a child in
the future
>> but it says he
>> it doesn't say it says
>> so he can never have
>> so the word means he can in the future
have a child so actually The Quran is in
doing us a favor again here just like in
chapter 65 ay 4. Thank you very much.
>> When is lem is strictly a past tense.
It's used to say this has never happened
before. So if I say
>> so it can happen in the future.
>> You have to prove that's that just
because something never happened before
doesn't mean it can happen in the
future.
>> Why not?
>> Okay.
>> Allah says if he wants he can. So he
can. If he wants he can. And this is why
this according to the Sunni sources
according to Omar Allah has children and
it's an authentic but I know you don't
believe in it but just to give you an
example how in the Sunni sources
actually Allah is a father in some sense
but
>> okay so I'd like to first go to what you
said you said just because it says len
that means that it's possible in the
future correct
>> lem not you're corrupting the Quran
again my friend
>> I know because it says lem it's possible
in the future
>> lem not len lem
>> and What does len directly means? It
said this
>> it can mean in the future he can
>> it can mean in the future he can. But
what does it directly mean?
>> No, it it as it is in the ayah as it is
in the ay it can mean that in the future
he can have children. I'm just going
what by what the says you know I don't
need to
>> I understand but just means that this
has never happened in the past. That's
what [clears throat]
>> so it can happen in the future.
>> It can it can happen in the future.
>> Exactly. And this is why for example let
me let me tell you it says
he does not give birth right. So
actually if we have to compare for
example Allah with Satan and we go to
the tap of chapter 18 ayah of 50 this
proves that you know Allah doesn't give
birth that means he can lay eggs just
like Satan in Islam lays eggs every
morning and and Satan has a male private
part. Let me finish brother. Then a male
private part and a female private part
and he does it to himself and that's how
he can he's able to produce offspring.
So this proves again that Allah is like
Satan. He can
>> Okay. Rob staying on topic.
>> I am on topic.
>> Okay. Lem. Right. So if I said using the
word lem that there has never been two
gods before, does that mean there can be
two gods in the future? Just because I
used lamb
>> it he can have offspring he can take I'm
answering so in the future it's possible
for Allah to do that
brother hold on let me finish so it
doesn't forbid Allah you cannot forbid
Allah to take children in the future
because else Allah would have used Allah
should have used if he's the best
communicator according to you Muslims if
Allah is the perfect communicator he
should have used len instead of lamb but
He didn't.
>> So,
>> it's not that hard.
>> I'm going to ask you just because I said
something has never happened in the
past.
>> So, if I say there has never been two
gods in the past, that means I'm saying
that there can be two gods in the
future. That's exactly what you're
saying.
>> Yeah. But the problem is we have another
contradiction. Hold on. There is another
contradiction because if you read then
chapter 5:18, Allah denies that he's the
father of the Jews and the Christians.
So, we you still have a problem, a
dilemma to deal with. Either way you
cooked.
>> I have a question based on the the
actual verse in the statement cuz this
isn't making sense to me that when Allah
says that if he if he wanted to he could
have or would have that that's that that
means that he actually can't. It's like
just saying the opposite. If I
>> It's a rhetorical question to show the
disbelie.
>> It's not a rhetorical question. It's a
hypothetical.
>> Yeah. It's an impos it's an impossible
>> No, it's not. So if I were Okay. If I
said if I wanted to have a pet, then I
would have gone to the pet store and
chosen from from the dogs. Does that
mean that it's impossible for me to go
to the pet store? That I'm saying that
that I'm actually saying I can't
actually do that when I said that I
>> that's because you're using that.
>> That's because you're using a possible
hypothetical. For example, an impossible
hypothetical. I could say, how could a
square have five sides without breaking
the laws of geometry?
>> That's not a hypothetical. That's a
That's a question. A straight up
straightforward question. A hypothetical
is a if then. If this then this. That's
hypothetical. If this, then this.
>> Okay. Fine. So,
>> run just really quick.
>> If I say if I wanted a pet, if I wanted
to choose a pet, if I had willed to
choose a pet, I would have gone to the
pet store and picked up a dog. Yeah,
that's
>> what what am I communicating?
>> You're communicating a possible hypo
hypothetical.
>> But what exact am I saying in the in the
statement? What am I telling you? What
am I communicating to you?
>> You're saying that if the first
condition was met, then the second
consequent would be the consequence.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I got you.
That would be the case.
>> If I had if I had willed,
>> it's possible that I would have done
this. If I wanted to, this would have
been the action. If I wanted to,
>> that would be the case.
>> The action is possible.
>> That would be the case if the if the
word in was used as the conditional
particle. But in this case, it's
>> has nothing to do with that. It has to
do with the just the statement. The the
statement says if Allah had will to take
a son, he could have chosen from his
creation or in your words would have
chosen from his creation. It's
communicating something that Allah could
have done if he wanted to. He just
didn't want to. So that's why he has no
kid.
>> Avery, I'm going to give you an example
of a hypothetical that doesn't show the
con the con the condition is possible.
If I were to say if a square had five
sides, it would break the laws of
geometry. Is that a hypothetical?
>> Yes.
>> And did it make the Just because it was
a hypothetical, did it make the
condition possible?
>> If it's a hypo repeat that question,
sorry.
>> Just because What?
>> Just because it was a hypothetical, did
it make the condition possible?
>> Not not necessarily. That's that's
reality.
>> The same case applies to this verse.
Just because it was a hypothetical, but
hold on. Make the condition.
>> Let me let me show you how it's how Let
me show you how it's not different. Does
Does a square have will?
>> No.
>> Oh. So, this is what we would call
something that is um what's it called? A
false equivalence. When you're comparing
an an entity with a will who applies his
will to something and say he would have
done this if he willed versus an an
inanimate object and a fact about an
inanimate object saying if a square
would have had five uh sides or whatever
five angles then it would then it would
break the laws of gra you know physics
or whatever right
>> you would equivalent
>> got you equivalent agree let me land
So it's not analogous when we're talking
about Allah who has a will, who has a
mind and communicates and says, "Hey
guys, to refute you saying that I have a
son, this is my response to you. If I
wanted to have a son, I could have
chosen from my creation or I would have
chosen from my creation." That's
communicating that Allah could have if
he wanted to.
>> But you would agree. You would agree
that there can be hypotheticals that do
not affirm the condition is possible.
>> Sure.
>> Okay. What does that how does
>> So just because there's a hypothetical
that says if God did this, just because
there's a hypothetical that has that,
that doesn't mean that the condition is
possible.
>> So what what I need you to do, my
brother, is I need you to make that
here. Bring that here to be saying I
would. If I wanted to, I would have. If
I wanted to, I would have. Meaning that
when they're saying that they would have
actually means that they couldn't in the
first place. So it means that they
actually would not have. Like for
example, if Allah if Allah wanted to
take a son, could he have taken from his
creation?
>> No.
>> So then he's lying.
>> Wait, wait, repeat the question.
>> Oh, you're out of the fold of Islam now.
>> Repeat the Sorry, I didn't hear the
question.
>> I got you. I got you. If if Allah wanted
to take a son, could he have taken could
he have chosen from his creation?
>> It's two impossibilities. If that
impossib If the first impossibility was
met, if the first impossibility was met,
then yes, the second impossibility would
be met as well.
>> So notice this that the result is based
on the the the the condition. The
condition is Allah's will. That's the
condition. If he had willed to do this,
then he could have done this.
>> So according to the verse, if Allah had
willed to take a son, he could have.
That's the point. But you're saying it's
impossible for Allah to will to have a
son in the first place, right?
>> Yes. Because the person earns that.
>> Okay. So when it says that if Allah had
will to take a son, then this is already
Allah contradicting himself acting as if
by because he continues to say if he had
will to take a son, then he would have
he would have chosen from the creation.
But unfortunately for Allah, it's
actually impossible for you to will that
in the first place. So why are you using
this as a reputation as if it makes
sense?
>> Because it's used as a rhetorical
statement to make the disbelievers
think. Because the whole point is the
whole point is the whole point is you're
giving God these these sons that are so
heinous. Some of them were disgusting.
The statues, right?
>> Why why would those be the sons when
there could be beautiful angels?
>> Who cares? You know what? He actually
uses this, right? Uh Rob, Allah gets mad
that they're giving him daughters and
not sons, right, Rob?
>> Yep. Yep. Yep.
>> So he
>> Allah didn't like women. Allah didn't
like daughters. Yeah.
>> Yes. So he
>> show them how it's a rhetoric to show
them how stupid it is to think that God
would pick this over another.
>> No, he actually gets mad if they're
giving him sons.
>> Avery. Avery, can you please can you
please just search up what does the
conditional particle L a W in Arabic
mean?
>> Yeah, I don't I I my brother, I I'm
taking I I couldn't care less
>> about what somebody makes up of some uh
conditional participle particle,
whatever.
>> Um, and then they say, "Oh, well, when
this is used, this means that it's
actually an impossible thing." That's
not what the verse says. Because if it
was a if it was a possible if it was a
possible condition, the the particle in
or either would have been used.
>> Let me go with you. You don't even got
to finish explaining. Let me go with
you. So it's impossible for Allah to
even will to have a son in the first
place. Correct.
>> According to the verse. Yes.
>> Okay. So according to the verse, it's
impossible for Allah to will to have a
son.
>> So what is he getting them to think
about? because you said that the reason
why he gives them this response is to
get them to get them get them to think
and see how futile and uh unreasonable
it is to say that he has a son anyway
that he has offspring at all.
>> So if this is impossible for him to will
to do,
>> how does that answer them?
>> I got you. So the question is very
simple. So even if God could do that,
even if God could do that, why would he
choose disgusting, heinous statues
rather than beautiful angels to be his
sons?
>> That's not his response. His response is
if he wanted to do that, then he could
have chosen it from any of his creation.
If the impossible So if the impossible
condition of him wanting to do that was
met,
>> why would he why would he pick those
heinous statues
>> instead of anything he could pick in his
entire creation? That's the question.
>> I need your help. I need your help
>> in this moment. I need you not to add to
the verse.
>> I need you add to the verse because the
verse Hold on. Does the verse say
anything about Allah having a preference
of offspring that they're ascribing to
him? Well, when it says he would have
picked from whatever he created.
>> So, does that mean he has a preference
among his creation or it's up to him?
>> It's up to him.
>> Very good. So, it's up to him. That the
the verse has nothing to do with why
would I choose these disgusting type of
creatures rather than these beautiful
creatures. That's not what the verse
says. The verse just simply says,
>> hold on. The verse simply demonstrates
and forget demonstrated. It says that he
would choose whatever he willed from his
creation. So again, you're saying that
the point of him using this impossible
nonsense is to get them to think how
does it get how does this refute them?
How does that how does this get them to
think that you know what it's actually
impossible for Allah to have a son in
the first place when he's saying the
opposite. He's not saying the opposite
because if you understood Arabic, you
would know that the particle used
predicts that the following are
impossible.
>> So, it's not saying the opposite. It's
saying exactly what I'm saying.
>> All right, I'll rest it here.
>> All right, man. Well, I'll bring up
another guest. Um, you know, we're just
at an impass here,
>> but I appreciate you uh appreciate you
trying. You can keep coming as well. You
know, I like you, so you can come back
again. Okay.
>> Um, sorry. Sorry if I was getting like
passionate and stuff. I didn't
>> That's how that's that's how this is. I
didn't I didn't
>> Maybe I was a little rude somewhere
within it. So, I do apologize if I was.
>> Brother, you don't got to do that. There
was no point where you were rude. You
were passionate, not rude. There's a
difference. You could be passionate and
have good dialogue like we did today.
It's all good.
>> But before he goes, brother, um, as a
Shia, uh, you know, I find it
fascinating that you're trying to defend
this while you believe that the Quran is
corrupted. And I believe that
>> No, we don't. No, we don't.
>> Yes, we do. because I can show you an
authentic
because I believe that actually in your
Quran Allah would have stated before
removing all of these verses by you
Muslims that Allah would have stated
that he would have have taken a son
because let me ask you a question. How
many verses are in your today's Shia
Quran in total 6,200 what?
>> Let me search it up.
>> Yeah, look it up.
>> Yeah. um gvt.com
>> 6,346
I think.
>> Yeah, watch this. Let me drop the hadith
too for brother got logic if you want to
respond to it cuz I already know I
already know that.
>> Yeah, hold on. Hold on, brother. If a
brother got logic, can you pull up the I
just dropped in the chat on the screen
and so he can read it. And by the way,
it's the hadith is completely perfect,
completely fine. Let him read it.
Remember 6,200 something, right?
>> Yeah. And how how how how big was the
Quran according
>> according to this hadith? It was 17,000.
>> 17,000. So more than half of the Quran
went missing according to
>> So are you now going to let me respond?
Okay. So something you're
misunderstanding about hadith sciences
and shi is that even if a hadith is we
reject it if it goes against the Quran
and that's made very clear made very
clear the author of kafi in the very
beginning of the book he said whatever
hadith I narrate in this check with it
with the Quran if the Quran proves it's
true then then accept it if the Quran
>> beautiful now show me in the Quran then
show me in the Quran where the Quran
says there are only 6,200 something ayat
you won't find it. So
>> the Quran 15:9 it says that it was
preserved perfectly.
>> Uh so
>> so if it was
>> how does this hadith contradict the
Quran? It doesn't. It's only saying that
originally the hadith was 70,000 verses.
>> The Quran that we have now is around
6,000. The hadith says that it's 17,000.
If it was properly preserved, then if it
was properly preserved, then what we
have right now is the actual Quran. And
the Quran affirms in chapter 15:9 that
the Quran is preserved. Meaning that the
Quran we have now is the original Quran.
And the Quran we have now is is the
Quran with about 6,000 verses. So
therefore, this hadith contradicts the
Quran. And according to the very author
of this book, I just explained to you
how it does.
>> No, it doesn't. To be fair, the chapter
15:9 doesn't say the Quran. It says the
reminder
>> and then 156. What is it? What does 156
define the reminder as the Quran?
>> Well, no it doesn't.
>> It says the book that was revealed to
Muhammad was the
>> Okay. So, let's go ahead and pull this
up cuz then the next verse actually
talks about the things before the Quran.
>> So, 156 it says, "Oh, you have been who
have been sent the correct?" So, what is
what was Muhammad revealed?
>> Why why are you saying why are you
saying this is Muhammad?
>> Because who is the Quran talking to? Who
was it revealed to?
>> That's why I'm asking you why why are
you assuming that it's talking about
what's revealed to Muhammad?
>> Because the Quran was revealed to
Muhammad.
>> And the reminder was also given to Moses
and Aaron and Jesus. Right? So why are
you saying that this is automatically
about Muhammad?
>> Because the claim that's being made
calling Muhammad crazy, that's what the
verses reference.
>> It doesn't say that though. But let me
grant you that to you. Let's say let's
say we give that that this is talking
about Muhammad. [clears throat] It's
ambiguous, but let me give it to you.
It's talking about Muhammad and Muhammad
was given a reminder. That's true.
>> Yeah.
>> Why are you saying that verse 9 says
that the reminder is about Muhammad is
the Quran.
>> Okay, perfect. So the context that's
given based on the context that's given
since you said you accepted my premise
then based not accept it for the sake of
the debate of course. So then based on
the context given what is the
uh defined as based on the context given
according to the premise you accepted
for the sake of the debate.
>> Yeah. To me to me it looks like the
vicar would be Allah's revelation in
general because in verse 6 if we're
saying that that's the Quran in verse 9
and 10 in verse 10 it mentions the
messengers before Muhammad right after
saying that Allah guards the reminder.
>> Of course. Yeah.
>> So it seems that if we're being
charitable, I think that it would
include all the books as being the
reminder in verse 9 that Allah guards.
>> Yeah. But the following the following
verse doesn't reference the at all. It
doesn't reference reminders at all.
>> It so what it and the verse six doesn't
reference Muhammad, right? But we're
taking that from what?
>> But you said you accepted it for the
sake of the debate.
>> Yeah. So because of if we're going with
context then the very next verse that
mentions after Allah protects the
reminder and he guards it he mentions
sending messengers before Muhammad of
old. So the revelation that they have as
well.
>> So where is that inclusion made?
>> Right here indeed we have we sent
messengers before you amongst the sex of
old.
>> Yeah. But where is that where is the
inclusion made in regards to the the
reminder because the only inclusion made
so far based on the context is
>> you you agree that the previous
scriptures are also the reminder right?
>> Yeah they are reminders.
>> Okay so when the Quran says that it
indeed we it is we who guard the
reminder and then immediately
>> wait so just so we're clear it says the
reminder meaning only one.
>> Oh only one
>> it says the reminder. Okay. So when in
1643 when Allah says go ask the people
of the reminder, who is he talking
about?
>> They're talking about the the Jews and
Christians that converted to Islam.
>> The Jews and the Christians. It doesn't
say that converted to Islam. It says the
people of the Okay. So it says the Jews
and the Christians. Do the Jews and the
Christians have the same book?
>> You said 1643.
>> Yeah.
>> Where does it say Jews or Christians?
>> It says the people of the reminder. I
asked you who the people of the reminder
were. You said Jews and Christians.
>> I said I said the Muslims that converted
from Judaism Christians.
>> The Jews and the Christians who
converted to Islam. That's what you
said.
>> The Jews and Christians that converted
to Islam. So when they are Muslims,
that's what the verse is referring to by
>> No. Well, that you can you can say that
if you want. That's not what that's not
what that means at all, but I'll let
you. Who cares? So you agree that the
people of the reminder are Jews and
Christians, correct? people of the
reminder. Yeah, they could be Jews and
they could be Christians.
>> Oh, they are.
>> They are. It's not they could be. They
are the Jews and the Christians. So when
it says when it's referring to the Jews
and the Christians as the people of the
Al Vicar, the reminder, do they have the
same book?
>> Do the Jews and Christians have the same
book as what?
>> Do they have the same book as each
other? Do they follow the same book?
>> No.
>> Right. So they the Jews have the Torah,
the Christians, they have the Gospel,
they have the NGO. Right.
>> Yeah. So they have two different books
yet they are still called the people of
Al reminder as in one reminder like you
said.
>> So where are the real quick? Where are
the Jews and Christians called
the people of the reminder?
>> You brother you you trolling me man? Are
you trolling me Rita? Maybe
>> I'm sorry because 16 1643 doesn't
mention anything about Jews and
Christians. So I'm just asking where
>> Rita I I don't I like you man. So, I'm
not I don't want to have to do the watch
your clip back thing.
>> Yeah, I got you. I got you.
>> You just said multiple times.
>> Yeah.
>> That the Jews and Christians are the
people of the reminder. That's what you
said multiple times, dude. You agreed
with that.
>> Yeah, they they are people of reminder,
but I don't believe that they're the
people of reminder referred to in this
in this verse right here.
>> Okay. So, then who are they then? When
it says talking to when Muhammad is
talking and says you know uh you know we
did not send when it says to him we did
not send messages before you except men
right and it says and if you do not know
then go and ask the people of the
reminder.
>> Yeah but people reminder
>> could people reminder also refer to
Muslims?
>> No not before Muhammad
>> is it telling Muhammad to go ask
Muslims? It's it's telling him to go
ask,
>> right? Are the other Muslims does
Muhammad need to go to Muslims to ask
about what Allah is telling him about?
Do the Muslims have that information?
>> No.
>> Who does? Who does, brother?
>> Who has knowledge of what Allah revealed
to the prophet?
>> Only him.
>> Mhm.
>> Let's do this again.
>> It says, "And we sent not before you any
but men whom we inspired."
>> Are we on 1610 right now? 1643.
>> Uh, yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. 1643.
Okay. I'm on it. Yeah.
>> So Allah says to Muhammad, "The we sent
not before you except men." They were
just men, right? Who that we inspired.
>> Yes.
>> Those are the prophets before Muhammad.
Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. And then Allah says to him,
"So ask those the people of the reminder
if you do not know." So if you don't
know Muhammad what I'm telling you about
that the people I sent before you were
just men these prophets of old before
were men then go and ask those who go
and ask the the people of the reminder
who are they can't be the Muslims cuz
they know as much as Muhammad knows.
>> Could it could it have been the the
Muslims that converted from Judaism and
Christianity because they also they also
had believed in the Torah and the
gospel. So if let's say the some of
these people converted.
>> So he needs to go ask the Jews and
Christians who believe in him as a
prophet. Yeah. To get this
>> hear about the stories of the prophets
that came.
>> Okay. And what were their books that
they're getting this information from?
>> They're getting it from uh the Torah and
the Gospel that they
>> that they have.
>> So So the Torah and the Gospel are
identified as Allah reminder together,
right?
>> Yeah. So just because it says Allah of
reminder doesn't mean it's talking about
one singular book. So when 159 says that
Allah guards al
your rebuttal was well it's al reminder
meaning it's only talking about one
singular thing. No cuz al reminder can
refer to multiple things multiple books
all at once.
>> Um brother god logic on top of that you
know I don't want to make it too hard on
this person because clearly he didn't
read his book. Actually when we showed
you the authentic hadith uh you know
from uh
actually the scholars are saying and
it's also in Kulini uh in Kulani he I
have a book here that says literally
that this schol explains that hadith he
says that al keni truly believed what he
what he said in that hadith so yes it's
authentic but he believed in it yet you
a modern day shia in 2026 you think that
you know better than [clears throat] I
ali
that's there are people that claimed
believed in the hadith distortion there
are people who think he
>> did this yeah the scholars yeah that's
how they explain so he truly believed in
it and and and the hadith there's no
issue with it so you still have a
dilemma my brother either way and on top
of that I believe that you Shia unlike
the Sunnis you believe that when Imam
Mahi comes you believe in a guy called
Imi He's the last im.
>> This is I think you're the 12 12, right?
>> Yes, I am.
>> You think that the last im will bring
with him the correct Quran with the
correct explanations, right?
>> The cor Yeah. [clears throat] The
correct exodus, the correct explanation
of the Quran.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So, you're waiting for
the real explanation. God logic. Take
this as a note. Shia believe that the
correct 100% correct explanation for the
Quran will be brought by this guide in
the future called Imam Mahi. So they
don't they have to speculate actually
the meaning of the Quran but
>> all right.
>> Yeah. Um God you should probably move
on. Um
>> okay.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Take care of yourself, man. I
appreciate you.
>> Hopefully we talk again once again.
Sorry if I did seem rude in any way,
shape or form.
>> Um
>> good. You were good. All love. I'll see
you.
>> Yes, sir. Peace. All right, that was
Rita.
>> Uh, man. Muslims, I guess, it's
interesting because Muslims that we're
getting, we're we're hearing them say
that they wouldn't do something that
Muhammad did based on their preference.
Um, even though Muhammad did it, they're
not condemning it, but they're saying
they wouldn't do it. So, you're still
morally better than Muhammad cuz you
wouldn't do these actions, but you're
still on a bad end on the moral side for
not being able to condemn said action
because you know you're going against
your prophet. And that's unfortunate.